Thomas you seem particularly triggered
right now can you tell me what happened
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am i crazy we don't use that word in here
if you want the truth near you're going
to have to follow me anything that matters
to you is still here i know it's why you're
still fighting and why you will never give up
you don't know me no
after all these years to be going back to
where it all started back to the matrix
Welcome back to the matrix everyone what year is
it this is going to be my matrix resurrections
trailer breakdown so obviously there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs and familiar stuff a bunch
of the cast from the original matrix trilogy
is back for this so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos of course i'll
do videos for this when the movie comes out later
this year it'll be coming out around the time that
spiderman no way home is hitting theaters so it'll
be a really big christmas and holiday season this
year but i'll just start at the beginning of the
trailer footage and work our way through shot by
shot there's not a ton of dialogue in this and i
feel like they don't need it because i feel like
the white rabbit song does most of the work and
there is a little bit of dialogue just enough to
give you clues about who some of these characters
are especially the whole morpheus twist of it all
everybody wondering why lawrence fishburne said
that he was not a part of this movie like oh oh
i get it now the title of the movie is all about
resurrections there's this theme of reincarnation
inside the matrix movies that they talk about
during the original trilogy the reincarnation
of the one neo so a lot of these other characters
are playing younger versions of the other
characters who are reincarnations of the other
characters but the way they start the trailer is
a much older version of neo who's been put back
into the matrix because the last we saw of him in
matrix revolutions after he defeated agent smith
after he defeated all the smiths he looked like he
actually died sacrificing himself at machine city
thus began the truce between the machines and the
people just like this loose piece that they had
and it was just this hanging idea that they would
have this truce that would exist for however long
it could exist with the oracle and the architect
just sort of arguing with each other about how
long it could possibly exist presumably that piece
is going to end during the matrix resurrections
but the way they're kind of playing in here is
that there's been another cycle of zion in all
the characters that did not get put back into
the matrix that aren't the older versions of
themselves from the previous trilogy like the
actors that came back the younger versions are the
ones who were reincarnated so to speak rebooted in
a new cycle of zion so it just seems like that's
why some of them are younger but not other ones
and the way the architect later explained it is
that neo was just the latest in a long line of
reincarnations of this one and he just happened
to look like this so theoretically when neo
died another person would become the one and be
reincarnated and they would look different so i'm
assuming what they're saying here in the fact that
keanu reeves is much older during this movie neo
looks much older even though they call him thomas
because he's back in the matrix is that he did not
die at the end of matrix revolutions the machines
just plugged him back into the matrix and then
just started dosing him up quote unquote with the
blue pills even though they have this big metaphor
for the blue pill inside the trailer like they're
over medicating him so that he won't remember that
he is the one something happened to his memory
in the memory of some of the other people to make
them forget like it seems like trinity also does
not know that she is part of this group of people
they were somehow put back into the matrix
and made to forget what had happened
but the trailer basically starts with him in
a therapy session with neil patrick harris who
seems like he's either a program or he's an agent
there's a couple characters in here i'm wondering
if they're the architect like jonathan groff looks
like he's an agent but he could also be another
version of the architect as well because there's
a whole other younger version of the oracle in
this as well like you see the glasses oh clearly
she's meant to be another version of the oracle
while he's in the therapy session you start to
see all the familiar triggers like he notices
glitches in the matrix so to speak he notices the
black cat that they explained to him oh you saw it
twice that's because it's a glitch in the matrix
sometimes those happen when he talks about the
dreams that he's had that seem very real it sounds
like he's remembering the events of the original
trilogy the way they cut the trailer i think is
kind of misleading like he's not remembering all
this matrix code around him talking about the
dreams this is something from later in the movie
then there's a whole bunch of flashes with an
agent trying to shoot him him stopping time and
then they flash to the real world inside machine
city with a bunch of machines inspecting his body
and it seems like this is meant to be and it seems
that they're trying to imply that this is his body
in present day like they still have his body
and this is what it looked like ever since the
events of matrix revolutions like they just kept
it they never gave it back to the people of zion
after they finished their mission you see a bunch
of smaller machine spiders and what seems like the
younger version of morpheus attacking a bunch
of flashes and then neo in present day waking
back up just like he woke up in the original
matrix movie inside the real world like wait
a minute what's going on here i also love the
way that neil patrick harris's character says
we don't use that word in here crazy talking about
inside the matrix obviously because he's either a
program or an agent then you see him during a
day inside the matrix going through his paces
with a bunch of familiar easter eggs in the whole
theme of the white rabbit song reminding you of
the white rabbit during the original movie follow
the white rabbit as they told him real big alice
in wonderland allegory about him following the
white rabbit down the hole to learn the truth
about what was going on inside the matrix we
see in me trinity you kind of see the events of
the trailer play out similar to the plot of the
original matrix movie like first he feels like
something is weird something isn't quite right
about his life then he meets trinity inside the
matrix obviously the context was very different
during the original film but here it seems like
trinity also does not realize yet that she is
inside the matrix again she experiences a version
of deja vu which they say is kind of like a glitch
in the matrix have we met before oh yes of course
you see him downing all those prescription
blue pills clearly something the machines
are giving him to manipulate his memory so that
he will not remember everything that's happened
because he's probably the most dangerous person
on the planet to them of course they will want
to keep the truth from him about who he really
is and what his abilities are the whole thing
with everybody in the elevator staring at their
phone screens is also meant to be a metaphor for
modern day culture and how everyone so to speak
is kind of trapped in a version of the matrix
it's a very obvious metaphor they're going for
here where you see neo is the only person who's
actually looking up everybody's eyes are stuck on
their screens you see another alice in wonderland
book with a depiction of the white rabbit and
it belongs to this younger version of the oracle
who just smiles at him you see him staring to
the mirror this is obviously from later in the
film where he sort of sees different depictions
of himself like a much older different looking
version of himself i think this is also meant to
look like a previous version of the one like he's
a reincarnation of the one so this might be one
of the previous versions of the one looked like
and if you were sure about him playing a version
of young morpheus i feel like this scene here
is just so iconic for lawrence fishburne's version
of morpheus in the first film that this has to be
morpheus when he says time to fly obviously that's
a reference to him flying during the events of the
first film that was basically the ending of the
first film with him fully coming into his power
then taking off flying before they slam to the
end credits i'm not sure which character jessica
henwick is playing she might be a reincarnation
of one of the other characters or she could be a
totally new character but she also has the white
rabbit tattoo this seems like her taking him to
that meeting with morpheus then they had the same
iconic scene of them fighting kung fu style i know
kung fu the twist being neo doesn't quite yet
know who he is at this point but he still does
know kung fu pretty well like he doesn't
understand what's going on but just stops
him short and then unleashes his power in this
explosion of energy and light so it just seems
like the process of him shaking the effect of
the drugs that the machines have been giving
him for all these years making him forget that
he is the one the scene will seem very familiar
it's right out of the first film is them showing
you the wide shot when he's explaining to neo how
humans are being grown to be batteries the whole
idea at the end of the matrix revolutions though
is that they didn't actually stop the machines
completely they just came to a true so machines
continued to harvest humans it's just that they
didn't destroy zion they left zion alone that
was the truce this is them traveling through the
depths of the original human civilization like
they did during the first movie when they were
traveling to zion neo and trinity on top of a high
rise while they're inside the matrix seeming like
they're still kind of coming to the realization
about who they really are what their relationship
is how they know each other this seems like it's
happening relatively early in the movie when
jessica henwick's character is first trying to
help neo learn the truth you see a bunch of agents
hijacking normal people inside the matrix like
they did during the original movie it's a little
too blurry to see who it is that's pointing the
gun at neo during this scene here but it seems
like it's him still realizing who he is this just
seems like one of the big action set pieces from
the movie on a train them on a train running from
the agents the whole idea of the train inside the
matrix and the original movies is that there was a
subway train a special one that would take them
outside and into the matrix if they wanted the
merovingian controlled the train that could take
them outside or into the matrix and i believe that
the mayor of indian from the original movies is
back for this movie as well too this seems like
a shot of trinity either coming out of or just
inside the matrix while she's still plugged in a
couple really big action set pieces after they've
started to learn about who they really are what
their powers are i'm also wondering if this scene
of what seems like young morpheus is him starting
to awaken for the first time again like they'll
also show him waking back up inside the matrix
at some point or how he originally woke up inside
the matrix we don't get a ton of his origin story
during the original trilogy but he does narrate
a lot of his life in his history before the
events of the first film speaking of his history
i believe jada pinkett smith is also back for this
movie as well too the big hotel fight here will
obviously remind you of the end of the first movie
a lot of these different action scenes very
similar to big action set pieces from the
original trilogy especially that first film like
him stopping all the bullets here with trinity
also all the big action set pieces on the rooftop
like many of the iconic rooftop fight scenes from
the first film them jumping off the high rise
together also reminds you of the first time
that he tried to use his powers so to speak
when they're trying to train him he jumps off
fails and just bounces off the ground in its way
of teaching him how the physics of the matrix
works like oh if you die in the matrix you die in
real life and the reason why i think that jonathan
groff might be playing a version of the architect
here is because of the chairs that they're sitting
in do these chairs that they're both sitting in
not remind you of the chairs that the architect
sat in in the original movies also his speech
patterns don't seem like a traditional agent's
speech patterns so remember the title of the movie
the theme of resurrection the idea that people
are resurrected with these different cycles that
they go through in the war against the machines
the whole cycle of zion that they tried to break
with the matrix revolutions movie everybody let
me know in the comments what you think of this
it looks like it's going to be pretty badass but
if you spotted any really big easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video just
write them below in the comments i've got a couple
other big videos that i'm working on so make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss that everyone click here for my full
shangxi movie post credit scene video and click
here for my full marvel what if episode 5 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!